once and for all he belonged here
he always had good habit match each like
and match a different image definitely
because have it the dictate of the
rhythm great great thank you so much oh
thank you Shere Khan arrives he's
playing with the court inventions he out
of it which is like a drop it what did I
say about your tricks what did I say no
more tricks
Mowgli is spoken for Shere Khan threats
especially during the water truths
pretty good yeah why not he can be a
good man
he's not ready he'll be killed
I can't live there you go that was great
because what what happens is a tendency
with your gonna try to chase after him
and he finally stops she says now you've
done your part people on him the time
mm-hmm you're gonna be not you're not
gonna look great you get it knocked
around all the walls I gotta be
everybody get to the river everybody get
to the river everybody get to the river
charge mobs come on stay close to me pop
stay close to me pops stay close to me
and that is really how though all those
must have been females up there females
sting me they look like males to me from
down here
sorry just put some honey on it honey
really
I can't you can't or you won't
I can't you will
there's a lot of bees up here yeah if
you wish we can take them home with us
don't worry they don't sting ow
that was a mosquito good all right hey
the whole sequencing you get a sense of
what now it's all going to be photo real
so it's all temporary looking NOC
stylized cartoony or anything you do yes
would you like to see yeah don't you
know what you are I know what you are I
know where you came from this strange
odor today what is it
this scent that I'm on upon but um-hmm
can't help but notice there's the
strange odor today what is it this scent
that I'm on
when was it we came to adopt man in the
jungle
there's just one thing we need to reach
our full potential
playing the add a red flower and we will
rule this jungle I will protect you
you
you
you
one bite
what's a little cleaning job right now
yeah well you are set up at the school
to wide open I'm seeing your face so
except big Chloe I'm giving you a
cannibal half hour before you jump so
that I have a moment that way
look up to me
I mean your eyes are awful that patient
of bourbon
perfectly clear as perfectly clear
that's the view up theirs you guys
looking up the cliff and these are the
real guys there are real people who
collect yeah that's where we got the
idea these are people they have lots of
setting up all right
you
we're here
okay yeah we got it check the gate
excellent good work everybody
you